Alice: 能跟我分纯酸奶吗
Alice: Can you share plain yogurt with me?
Lucia: 可以啊
Lucia: Sure.
Alice: 那我们要这个吧
Alice: Then let's get this one.
Lucia: 可以啊这个是他是一整盒
Lucia: Sure, it's a whole box.
Lucia: 一大盒对嗯
Lucia: A big box, yes.
Alice: 对但是每人200克对对对
Alice: Yeah, but everyone gets 200 grams each.
Lucia: 番茄每个人200克
Lucia: Tomatoes, 200 grams each.
Lucia: 对对也行
Lucia: Yes, that's fine too.
Lucia: 而且如果大家想吃也可以挖出来挖
Lucia: And if everyone wants to eat, we can scoop it out.
Lucia: 挖到碗里
Lucia: Scoop it into a bowl.
Alice: 然后我不要糖这里面会有一个蜂蜜
Alice: I don't want sugar, there will be honey in it.
Lucia: 嗯好的可以啊
Lucia: Okay, sure.
Lucia: 我喜欢加蜂蜜的
Lucia: I like adding honey.
Lucia: 我投票投票加入你的这个酸奶team
Lucia: I vote to join your yogurt team.
Alice: 它这个就两三个人的量
Alice: This is enough for two or three people.
Alice: 因为它比较酸
Alice: Because it's quite sour.
Alice: 它是纯酸奶那么
Alice: It's pure yogurt.
Alice: 你能喝纯酸奶吗
Alice: Can you handle pure yogurt?
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Yes, I can.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Alice: 就是你吃过纯酸奶
Alice: Have you had pure yogurt before?
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Alice: 这个一点糖都没了
Alice: This one doesn't have any sugar.
Lucia: 会比会比普通这种酸奶要酸一些
Lucia: It will be more sour than regular yogurt.
Alice: 没事你你可以买你的普通酸奶
Alice: It's okay, you can buy your regular yogurt.
Alice: 因为我这个可能就两三个人
Alice: Because this one is probably just for two or three people.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure.
Alice: 你可以买普通的
Alice: You can buy the regular one.
Jake: 豆汁
Jake: Soy milk.
Katrina:  啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Ah, hahaha.
Tasha: 没有我只是看到了
Tasha: No, I just saw it.
Katrina:  你你喝过豆汁没
Katrina: Have you ever drunk soy milk?
Jake: 我喝过啊
Jake: Yeah, I've had it.
Lucia: 啊我没喝过啊
Lucia: Oh, I've never had it.
Jake: 哪哪一款
Jake: Which kind?
Jake: 哈哈哈多少钱啊
Jake: Haha, how much does it cost?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Lucia: 怎么如此热情哈哈
Lucia: Why are you so enthusiastic? Haha.
Shure:  看杨老板累的
Shure: Look at Jake, he's tired.
Shure:  给杨老板
Shure: Give it to Jake.
Katrina:  杨老板要喝豆汁
Katrina: Jake wants to drink soy milk.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice: 坐好
Alice: Sit down properly.
Jake: 行行行真的真的
Jake: Okay, okay, really, really.
Shure:  补补这3新币
Shure: Replenish with these 3 new coins.
Jake: 补补补补
Jake: Replenish, replenish, replenish.
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my.
Jake: 一个10块钱够了啊
Jake: Is 10 bucks enough?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Alice: 这一共三新币
Alice: This is a total of 3 new coins.
Shure:  一共3星币啊
Shure: A total of 3 new coins.
Jake: 我知道就是大概一个10新币
Jake: I know, it's about 10 new coins.
Alice: 一个10新币
Alice: About 10 new coins.
Shure:  就是在在在新加坡的
Shure: It's in Singapore.
Alice: 真的假的
Alice: Really?
Jake: 对在我在我家门口的那个商场里边
Jake: Yeah, in the mall near my house.
Lucia: 这么为什么
Lucia: Why is that?
Lucia: 你们不是靠海吗
Lucia: Aren't you near the sea?
Lucia: 怎么还这么贵
Lucia: Why is it still so expensive?
Jake: 我不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 他就是这个价啊
Jake: That's just the price.
Katrina:  新加坡物价这么贵
Katrina: Prices in Singapore are so high.
Jake: 一个10新币
Jake: About 10 new coins.
Shure:  快给杨老板补补
Shure: Quick, give Jake a refill.
Shure:  3新币咱可劲吃
Shure: We can really eat with 3 new coins.
Jake: 这多少个
Jake: How many is this?
Lucia: 所有的三新币吗
Lucia: All three new coins?
Jake: 这几个呀几个呀一二
Jake: How many, how many, one, two...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure:  10个左右大概
Shure: About 10, I think.
Jake: 10个100新币
Jake: 10 for 100 new coins.
Jake: 500块钱你花了3
Jake: You spent 3 out of 500.
Jake: 你花了3新币
Jake: You spent 3 new coins.
Shure:  3新币
Shure: 3 new coins.
Lucia: 一共三星币
Lucia: Total is three new coins.
Shure:  一共3新币
Shure: Total is 3 new coins.
Shure:  19块9啊 18块9是吧
Shure: 19.9, 18.9, right?
Alice: 晚上就要拆开这个
Alice: We'll open this tonight.
Shure:  3新币差不多
Shure: About 3 new coins.
Jake: 是是是你这大
Jake: Yes, yes, this big one.
Alice: 晚上就要拆开
Alice: We'll open it tonight.
Lucia: 可呀我们可以那个啥
Lucia: We can do that.
Jake: 你这哈哈哈
Jake: You... hahaha.
Lucia: 就是晚吃
Lucia: Just eat it later.
Jake: 中国我当500多了
Jake: I spent more than 500 in China.
Lucia: 晚饭的时候吃它刚好可以解腻
Lucia: Eating it at dinner will be perfect to cut the grease.
Jake: 哈哈哈虚报虚报
Jake: Hahaha, exaggerated, exaggerated.
Alice: 回去我就想吃这个
Alice: I want to eat this when we get back.
Lucia: 哇塞那这真的好好好划算啊
Lucia: Wow, this is really worth it.
Jake: 这个还是能感觉出来的
Jake: You can still feel it.
Katrina:  面包在哪来着
Katrina: Where's the bread?
Jake: 呵呵这in w的这个
Jake: Haha, this in W's place.
Katrina:  面包番茄酱
Katrina: Bread and ketchup.
Katrina:  姐你们面包也可以加酸奶是不是
Katrina: Sis, can you add yogurt to your bread?
Alice: 番茄酱
Alice: Ketchup.
Alice: 吃不惯面包
Alice: I can't get used to bread.
Katrina:  哈哈啊
Katrina: Haha, oh.
Katrina:  在这面包是吗
Katrina: Bread is here, right?
Alice: 你去选你想要的
Alice: Choose the one you want.
Katrina:  我就买那普通的切片面包就行
Katrina: I'll just get the regular sliced bread.
Katrina:  明天早饭是自己弄是吧
Katrina: We're making our own breakfast tomorrow, right?
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Katrina:  就随便拿
Katrina: Just grab anything.
Katrina:  这种我都行
Katrina: This kind, I'm okay with it.
Shure:  现代吐司来吧
Shure: Let's go with modern toast.
Katrina:  买点什么酱呢
Katrina: What kind of spread should we buy?
Katrina:  搞奶酪吗
Katrina: Cheese?
Katrina:  还是搞果酱
Katrina: Or jam?
Katrina:  123我们6个人是不是拿两袋啊
Katrina: 123, there are 6 of us, should we get two bags?
Jake: 好啊
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  两袋搞一点什么呢
Katrina: What should we get with the two bags?
Katrina:  番茄酱在哪
Katrina: Where's the ketchup?
Katrina:  你们刚有看见吗
Katrina: Did you guys see it?
Alice:没注意到没看到
Alice: Didn't notice, didn't see it.
Katrina:  你吃面包吗
Katrina: Do you eat bread?
Katrina:  早上那他明天早上就让自己吃哎
Katrina: So, tomorrow morning he can just eat it himself.
Alice:我不吃面包
Alice: I don't eat bread.
Katrina:  怎么办那你吃点水果那种
Katrina: What about you, do you eat fruit or something?
Alice:无所谓我早上
Alice: I don't care in the morning.
Katrina:  不怎么吃东西啊
Katrina: You don't eat much in the morning?
Katrina:  早上面包里加搞点啥呢
Katrina: What should we put in the bread in the morning?
Alice:番茄片你吃番茄吗
Alice: Tomato slices. Do you eat tomatoes?
Lucia: 奶酪
Lucia: Cheese.
Katrina:  奶酪也行啊
Katrina: Cheese works too.
Alice: 看英国干巴老头吗
Alice: Have you watched that British old man?
Katrina:  看
Katrina: Yeah, I have.
Alice: 又做他的干巴lunch哈哈
Alice: He's making his dry lunch again, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈其实他那种果酱也很好看
Katrina: Haha, actually his jam looks pretty good.
Katrina:  就是他那个切的面包邦硬你知道吗
Katrina: But the bread he cuts is so hard, you know?
Alice: 梆硬然后
Alice: It's so hard and then...
Katrina:  他们说吃这个吗
Katrina: Do they really eat this?
Katrina:  英国人
Katrina: The British?
Alice: 然后搞点那个干巴黄油
Alice: And then add some of that hard butter.
Katrina:  也可以拿
Katrina: That works too.
Katrina:  果酱随便哎
Katrina: Jam is fine too.
Katrina:  有了哎还有奶油哎
Katrina: There's also cream.
Alice: 又做他的干巴lunch
Alice: He's making his dry lunch again.
Lucia: 柠檬塔味
Lucia: Lemon tart flavor.
Alice: 我们家是不是也有对对
Alice: Do we have it at home too?
Lucia: 对对咱们房子里还有奶油
Lucia: Yes, we still have cream in the house.
Lucia: 你是更想吃奶酪还是更想吃果酱
Lucia: Do you prefer cheese or jam more?
Katrina:  我无所谓
Katrina: I don't mind.
Alice: 干吧lunch
Alice: Dry lunch.
Katrina:  我想吃番茄酱
Katrina: I want to eat ketchup.
Alice: 那我们找番茄酱吧
Alice: Then let's find some ketchup.
Lucia: 也行那我可以拿一个这个吗
Lucia: Alright, can I take this one?
Lucia: 有人还有别人想吃吗
Lucia: Anyone else want some?
Katrina:  拿呗
Katrina: Go ahead.
Alice: 麻烦你拿了就有人吃
Alice: If you take it, someone will eat it.
Lucia: 那我拿了
Lucia: I'll take it then.
Lucia: 夹带私货
Lucia: Sneaking in some extra stuff.
Katrina:  我也夹带私货了
Katrina: I'm sneaking in some extra stuff too.
Katrina:  一罐冰淇淋
Katrina: A tub of ice cream.
Alice: 又做他的干巴lunch
Alice: Making his dry lunch again.
Shure:  感觉OK
Shure: Seems okay.
Alice: 番茄酱
Alice: Ketchup.
Alice: 那个
Alice: That one.
Shure:  番茄酱
Shure: Ketchup.
Alice: 她去找番茄酱了
Alice: She went to get ketchup.
Alice: 又做他的干巴lunch
Alice: Making his dry lunch again.
Alice: 番茄酱
Alice: Ketchup.
Shure:  杨老板累了
Shure: Jake is tired.
Jake: 一般啊
Jake: Just normal.
Alice: 干巴lunch
Alice: Dry lunch.
Alice: 你这边还有时间吗
Alice: Do you still have time?
Jake: 有吧我觉得还有40分钟左右
Jake: I think there's about 40 minutes left.
Lucia: 手动加拿大雪线啊
Lucia: Manually creating a snow line in Canada.
Lucia: 刚才路过过这个地方
Lucia: We passed by this place earlier.
Alice: 只有30多G了40分钟
Alice: Only 30+ GB left, 40 minutes.
Lucia: 哎帝王蟹腿
Lucia: Hey, king crab legs.
Jake: 差不多在这了是吧
Jake: Almost there, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 肢解了放这了
Jake: Dismembered and placed here.
Lucia: 对上次逛了时候还是鲜活的
Lucia: Yeah, last time we visited, it was still alive.
Lucia: 这次已经变成冷藏的
Lucia: This time it's already frozen.
Lucia: AI记着哈哈
Lucia: AI remembers, haha.
Katrina:  油油拿了是吧
Katrina: Got the oil, right?
Shure:  油有家里有油
Shure: No need, we have oil at home.
Alice:家里有
Alice: We have it at home.
Katrina:  那就OK了
Katrina: Then that's okay.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  够了
Katrina: That's enough.
Shure:  车子都放不下了
Shure: The
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  老板的眼神感觉
Shure: The boss's look...
Jake: 哈哈哈今天只有一车还行
Jake: Hahaha, only one car today, not bad.
Alice: only one
Alice: Only one.
Shure:  感觉钱包又被掏空了一次是吧
Shure: Feels like my wallet got emptied again, right?
Alice:为什么这个这么便宜
Alice: Why is this so cheap?
Jake: 是不是少个人呢
Jake: Are we missing someone?
Alice:哎那呢
Alice: Hey, over there.
Jake: 哪了
Jake: Where?
Alice:那呢
Alice: Over there.
Jake: 哦呵背景太绿了我看不出来
Jake: Oh, the background is too green, I couldn't see.
Tasha: 我想把这个拿出来不要了
Tasha: I want to take this out, I don't want it.
Tasha: 啊没咋
Tasha: Ah, it's nothing.
Tasha: 因为这两个才200
Tasha: Because these two are only 200.
Tasha: 可要40块钱
Tasha: But it costs 40.
Tasha: 这个300克
Tasha: This is 300 grams.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Tasha: 那我还回去
Tasha: Then I'll put it back.
Jake: 您好谢谢
Jake: Hello, thank you.
Shure:  拿三个袋吧
Shure: Take three bags.
Shure:  来吧开始吧
Shure: Come on, let's start.
Lucia: 我再去拿个车过来
Lucia: I'll go get another cart.
Lucia: 然后我们扫完的可以放另一个车里
Lucia: Then we can put the scanned items in the other cart.
Shure:  会员登录
Shure: Member login.
Shure:  今天谁登关注我
Shure: Who's logging in today?
其他人： 请扫入会员码
Others: Please scan the member code.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Alice: 我也行
Alice: I can do it too.
Katrina:  你也行是吧那你行
Katrina: You can do it, right? Then go ahead.
Alice: 看我有那个啥
Alice: Look, I have this thing.
其他人：会员录入失败
Others: Member entry failed.
Alice: 把我家地址给挡了
Alice: Block my home address.
Jake: 我我我试试
Jake: I'll try.
Jake: 这那个用的什么码呀
Jake: What code are we using?
Shure:  盒马APP
Shure: Hema app.
Katrina:  会员满
Katrina: Member full.
Jake: 一定要盒马是吧
Jake: It has to be Hema, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Alice: 我有但是我
Alice: I have it, but I...
Alice: 现在可以关吗
Alice: Can I turn it off now?
Jake: 呃你你我有你要一定要关吗干嘛呢
Jake: Uh, do you really need to turn it off? Why?
Tasha: 干嘛呢
Tasha: Why?
Shure:  我们在付钱
Shure: We're making a payment.
Alice:我好像 打不开
Alice: I can't seem to open it.
Jake: 那
Jake: Then...
Alice: 呀就把我家地址给漏了
Alice: Oh, my home address got exposed.
Jake: 好那请吧
Jake: Okay, please go ahead.
Alice:好吧
Alice: Alright.
Jake: 去吧就
Jake: Go ahead.
Shure:  好吧那又靠你了
Shure: Okay, it's up to you again.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 但是券已经用完了是吧
Jake: But the coupon is used up, right?
Tasha: 看看能不能买点
Tasha: Let's see if we can buy some.
Jake: 啊不用不用不用不用不用
Jake: No, no, no need.
Katrina:  那你会员可以免费领吗
Katrina: Can you get it for free with your membership?
Jake: 一新币的事情用不着
Jake: It's just one dollar, not worth it.
Shure:  是你的事情
Shure: It's your call.
Alice:普通
Alice: Just normal.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 二百九十八意念
Tasha: Two hundred and ninety-eight ideas.
Lucia: 我刚刚点开看了一下
Lucia: I just clicked to check.
Lucia: 我好像又掉线了
Lucia: I think I got disconnected again.
Lucia: 就在你说完之后
Lucia: Right after you finished talking.
Jake: 哦没关系
Jake: Oh, no worries.
Lucia: 我说我去检查一下
Lucia: I'll go check it out.
Jake: 你只要是亮着的就没关系
Jake: As long as the light is on, it's fine.
Lucia: 哦那就行
Lucia: Oh, that's good then.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 就是以防万一吧
Jake: Just in case.
Lucia: 他有时候会莫名其妙的掉线我觉得
Lucia: Sometimes it randomly disconnects, I feel.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 看看能不能买个这个
Tasha: Let's see if we can buy this.
Shure:  你试试吧
Shure: Give it a try.
Katrina:  对那个了吗
Katrina: Is it that one?
其他人：手机屏幕右下方按钮进行支付
Others: Use the button at the bottom right of the phone screen to make the payment.
Katrina:  到时候我们弄完了就往那边移
Katrina: When we're done, we'll move it over there.
Lucia: 可以把它先都弄开
Lucia: You can open it all up first.
Alice: 又做她的干吧lunch
Alice: Making her dry lunch again.
Alice: 肉放一块吧
Alice: Put a piece of meat.
Alice: 分类放
Alice: Sort them separately.
Katrina:  流水线工作
Katrina: Assembly line work.
Alice: 这个不能放下边会把它压了
Alice: This can't go at the bottom, it'll get squished.
Shure:  这个不能放下边
Shure: This can't go at the bottom.
Lucia: 这个等一下再放吧
Lucia: Let's put this later.
Lucia: 容易压扁
Lucia: It'll get easily squished.
Lucia: 重一点的也可以分开放
Lucia: Heavier ones can be separated too.
Lucia: 那个料酒
Lucia: That cooking wine.
Lucia: 要不然放这袋子里
Lucia: Or just put it in this bag.
Alice: 先别放这个了
Alice: Don't put this yet.
Alice: 不不不这个先放外边吧
Alice: No, no, no, put this outside first.
Alice: 把肉啥的搁过来吧
Alice: Put the meat and stuff over here.
Alice:或者是冷冻的菜也先不搁
Alice: Or the frozen veggies, let's not put them yet.
Alice:肉肉成盒的搁这
Alice: Put the boxed meat here.
Shure:  我快转晕了
Shure: I'm getting dizzy.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice: 旋转跳跃
Alice: Spin and jump.
Alice: 还有肉没
Alice: Any more meat?
Alice: 把那几个肉解开搁这里面吧
Alice: Unwrap those pieces of meat and put them in here.
Lucia: 放不下的话就放这袋子里
Lucia: If it doesn't fit, put it in this bag.
Jake:袋子哪领的呀
Jake: Where did you get the bags?
Lucia: 呃呃那边
Lucia: Uh, over there.
Alice: 买的
Alice: Bought them.
Jake: 哦买的呀哦
Jake: Oh, you bought them, I see.
Katrina:  哎还有一盒肉
Katrina: Hey, there's another box of meat.
Shure:  3个袋 4个袋子一新币差不多
Shure: Three bags, four bags for about one dollar.
Jake: 这么贵
Jake: That expensive?
Lucia: 这袋子这么贵哇
Lucia: These bags are that expensive?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 一箱亿新币啊
Jake: A dollar for one bag?
Lucia: 现在国内的袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Bags are expensive even back home now.
Jake: 这一块多钱
Jake: How much for one piece?
Alice: 并且他现在你外送的话必须买袋子
Alice: And you must buy bags for takeout now.
Jake: 这一块多钱一个袋子是吗我去
Jake: A dollar for one bag, seriously?
Shure:  一块5一个
Shure: One dollar fifty each.
Shure:  哎又给你换到6了哈哈哈
Shure: Oh, they raised it to six again, haha.
Lucia: 哎不过其实到哈哈哈
Lucia: But actually, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 不过其实到处袋子都收钱
Lucia: But actually, they charge for bags everywhere.
Lucia: 不过我没想到
Lucia: But I didn't expect
Lucia: 国内现在袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: bags to be this expensive here too.
Alice: 把那个调料给我吧
Alice: Pass me the seasoning.
Shure:  这个弄了吧
Shure: Let's do this.
Alice:好这袋就这样吧再加一个也行
Alice: Okay, this bag is fine as it is, or we can add one more.
Lucia: 这个感觉也可以放
Lucia: This one can be put in too.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one.
Katrina:  好
Katrina: Okay.
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Shure:  我们找找
Shure: Let's look for it.
Shure:  盒马呢
Shure: Where is Hema?
Lucia: 啊那这个要不放这袋子里
Lucia: Ah, should we put this in the bag?
Tasha: 我们昨天家今天买起来
Tasha: We bought it yesterday.
Tasha: 帮我开张卡的钱都可以省下来了
Tasha: We saved enough money to open a card.
Tasha: 开打之后打8.8折
Tasha: After opening, we get an 8.8% discount.
Jake: 好吧那应该开什么还是什么呀
Jake: Okay, so what should we open?
Tasha: 应该第一天就开
Tasha: It should have been opened on the first day.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  OK搞定
Shure: OK, done.
Jake: 卡多少钱
Jake: How much is the card?
Tasha: 只要298 跟嫁入土门是一个价格
Tasha: Only 298, same price as getting married into the Tu family.
Lucia: 要不然跟这个放一块
Lucia: How about we put this together with that?
Tasha: 258 好吧
Tasha: 258, okay.
Lucia: 因为面包袋子是纸
Lucia: Because the bread bag is paper.
Tasha: 他还比我便宜点
Tasha: It's a bit cheaper than mine.
Shure:  好来来来
Shure: Alright, come on.
Lucia: 这个放到这边
Lucia: Put this here.
Lucia: 然后这个放在这行吗
Lucia: And then put this here, is that alright?
Tasha: 付钱了吗已经
Tasha: Have you paid already?
Shure:  大小姐
Shure: Miss.
Shure:  对到付钱了
Shure: Yes, to pay.
Shure:  到最需要你的时候了
Shure: It's the moment we need you most.
Katrina:  你你是怎么给他报账的
Katrina: How do you report expenses to him?
Katrina:  每天都给他报账吗
Katrina: Do you report expenses to him every day?
Alice: 沉的给男人吧
Alice: Give the heavy things to the men.
Jake: 护弹使者
Jake: Bulletproof messenger
Shure:  这个又得端着了是吗
Shure: Do we have to hold this again?
Jake: 护弹使者
Jake: Bulletproof messenger
Katrina:  放放我这袋子
Katrina: Put this bag with me
Katrina:  别抱这个袋子
Katrina: Don't hold this bag
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Lucia: 咱们是不是还有个饮料没放到这里面
Lucia: Didn't we forget to put a drink in here?
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Oh, that's fine
Alice:没事走吧
Alice: It's okay, let's go
Jake: 那个还有是吗
Jake: Is there still something else?
Katrina:  那披萨我也来拿
Katrina: I'll take the pizza too
Alice: 那你喝的你拿着还是给你放着
Alice: Do you want to hold your drink or should I put it down?
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go
Alice: 蛋先
Alice: The egg first
Lucia: 这个能能放下吗
Lucia: Can this fit?
Lucia: 放不下我就拿着好了
Lucia: If it doesn't fit, I'll just hold it
Shure:  蛋还是
Shure: Is the egg still...
Lucia: 雨轩那个袋子会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Will Yuxuan's bag be a bit heavy?
Alice:先搁这里面
Alice: Put it in here first
Lucia: 这么鸡蛋可以和这个放一起对吧
Lucia: So, the eggs can go with this, right?
Tasha: 先放这吧要不要
Tasha: Put it here first, okay?
Alice:就先这样吧
Alice: Just leave it like this for now
Lucia: 也行可以都先放到车里
Lucia: Yeah, we can put everything in the car first
Lucia: 然后一会提的时候再拿出来
Lucia: And then take it out when we need it
Katrina:  go go go
Katrina: Go, go, go
Shure:  哦没买百事可乐我靠
Shure: Oh no, we didn't buy Pepsi, damn
Alice:盒马大采购
Alice: Big shopping at Hema
Jake: 为什么要百事可乐
Jake: Why do we need Pepsi?
Shure:  因为腌东西的那个百事会更甜一点
Shure: Because Pepsi is sweeter for marinating things
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Shure:  可口反正它就不好喝
Shure: Coke just doesn't taste as good
Jake: 好这能推到哪
Jake: Okay, where can we push this?
Lucia: 他不拦着咱咱就往外推哈哈哈
Lucia: If nobody stops us, we'll just push it outside, haha
Jake: 行
Jake: Alright
其他人：哎你好车子只能到这了
Others: Hey, you can only push the cart up to here
Jake: 失败大失败
Jake: Failure, big failure
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright
Shure:  直接这么拿应该就没问题
Shure: Carrying it like this should be fine
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Alright, alright
Shure:  那要要不你护蛋吧
Shure: How about you guard the egg?
Alice: 护蛋
Alice: Guard the egg?
Shure:  蛋对
Shure: Yes, the egg.
Alice: 护蛋笑死
Alice: Guard the egg, that's hilarious.
Alice: 护蛋使者是吗
Alice: Am I the egg guardian?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  当当当当当当当当当当当当当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun...
Lucia: 你这个任务艰巨
Lucia: This is a tough mission.
Lucia: 一定要保护好他哈哈
Lucia: You must protect it well, haha.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 谁把我的蛋撞碎了我就把谁撞死
Alice: If anyone breaks my egg, I'll break them.
Lucia: 哈哈哈好可怕
Lucia: Hahaha, that's so scary.
Alice: 确实我们疯P是这样的
Alice: Seriously, our crazy group is like this.
Lucia: 每天被撞的现代人
Lucia: Modern people getting bumped every day.
Alice: 精神状态良好
Alice: Mentally stable.
Lucia: 不我的精神状态不良好
Lucia: No, my mental state is not good.
Alice: 你吗
Alice: You?
Alice: why你会发疯吗
Alice: Why? Do you go crazy?
Lucia: 啊会
Lucia: Yeah, I do.
Lucia: 但大部分时候我都只是一只树懒
Lucia: But most of the time, I'm just a sloth.
Alice: 哈哈哈呆呆的反应慢慢的那种吗
Alice: Hahaha, slow and sluggish like that?
Lucia: 嗯我的
Lucia: Yeah, mine...
Lucia: 我精神上想成为一只树懒
Lucia: 但是很可惜我还是一只人类对
Lucia: But unfortunately, I'm still a human, right?
Alice: 你会
Alice: Will you...
Alice: 逼着自己快
Alice: Force yourself to speed up?
Lucia: 对对就是为了融入人类社会
Lucia: Yes, just to fit into human society.
Lucia: 我不得不把自己伪装的像人类一样
Lucia: I have to disguise myself to look human.
Katrina:  还要上去一层是不是
Katrina: Do we need to go up another level?
Shure:  还要上去一层
Shure: Yes, another level.
Lucia: 哈哈哈微微露出一个轻蔑的笑容
Lucia: Hahaha, showing a slight contemptuous smile.
Alice:上吧
Alice: Let's go up.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice: 又做他的干巴lunch
Alice: Making his dry lunch again.
Alice: 转转
Alice: Turn around.
Alice:走
Jake: 还得是用我的新加坡的拖鞋
Jake: It has to be my slippers from Singapore.
Tasha: 那个拖鞋走路就不不痛
Tasha: Those slippers don't hurt when you walk.
Jake: 这这底稍微厚一点
Jake: The sole is slightly thicker.
Alice: 打车吧
Alice: Let's take a cab.
Jake: 哎你还亮吗
Jake: Hey, are you still on?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Lucia: 哎这是一个扭蛋机吗
Lucia: Hey, is this a gacha machine?
Alice: 亮着呢
Alice: It's lit up.
Tasha: 这个能扭出啥来吗
Tasha: Can this machine dispense something?
Lucia: 好了我也是
Lucia: Alright, me too.
Lucia: 竟然扭不出来
Lucia: It actually didn't dispense anything.
Alice: 在干嘛
Alice: What's going on?
Tasha: 这肯定是有硬币要投币的
Tasha: There must be a coin slot, you need to insert coins.
Shure:  咱们6个人正好打一个商务
Shure: There are six of us, perfect for a business ride.
Alice: 机器还没弄好吧
Alice: Maybe the machine isn't set up yet.
Jake: 对打个商务好
Jake: Yeah, a business ride sounds good.
Alice: 走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Jake: 就在这等着吧
Jake: Let's just wait here.
Jake: 哎这边我看一下在哪打车哈
Jake: Hey, let me check where we can get a ride.
Shure:  应该这就行
Shure: This should be fine.
Shure:  那能停公交就能那啥
Shure: If a bus can stop here, so can we.
Jake: 在这在喜茶那合个影吧要不
Jake: Let's take a photo by the Hey Tea shop, shall we?
Jake: 就是或者就在这个地方也很
Jake: Or just right here, it's also good.
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Both are fine.
Lucia: 要扫一下喜茶吗
Lucia: Should we check out Hey Tea?
Jake: 我先打车
Jake: I'll call a ride first.
Shure:  没开吧那个
Shure: It’s not open, right?
Tasha: 应该在门外开了吧
Tasha: Maybe it's open outside.
Lucia: 哈哈打哈欠会传染
Lucia: Haha, yawns are contagious.
Jake: 那边那头去
Jake: Let's go over there.
Shure:  后门左拐
Shure: Turn left at the back door.
Jake: 看一下有更好的地方吗
Jake: Let's see if there's a better spot.
Shure:  门口不能停
Shure: You can't stop at the entrance.
Jake: 还是还是这吧行吧
Jake: Let's just stay here, okay?
Jake: 哎啥玩意
Jake: Hey, what is that?
Alice: 这个洞特别像一个怪笑的
Alice: This hole looks like a creepy smile.
Alice:这是 眼睛一个怪笑的东西
Alice: It's like eyes and a creepy smile.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 这吧行吧
Jake: This spot is good, right?
Jake: 这好
Jake: This works.
Alice: 两个大蝴蝶眼
Alice: Two big butterfly eyes.
Lucia: 定先把它放一下重啊
Lucia: Let's place it down first, it's heavy.
Alice: 咋啦
Alice: What’s up?
Alice: 洗不掉了
Alice: It won't come off.
Alice: 咋个办了不咋办
Alice: What to do now? There's nothing we can do.
Tasha: 累了
Tasha: I'm tired.
Alice: 累了
Alice: I'm tired.
Lucia: 加1
Lucia: Me too.
Alice: 加2
Alice: Me three.
Jake: 什么 10086 好的
Jake: What? 10086? Okay.
Alice: 10086
Alice: 10086.
Lucia: 哈哈哈 10086
Lucia: Hahaha, 10086.
Alice: 世上世上无难事
Alice: There's nothing difficult in this world
Alice: 只要肯乐
Alice: As long as you are happy.
Alice: 只要肯乐欢
Alice: As long as you are willing to be happy.
Alice: 什么意思
Alice: What does that mean?
Lucia: 世上无难事
Lucia: There's nothing difficult in this world.
Lucia: 只要肯乐观
Lucia: As long as you are optimistic.
Alice: 好乐观我看成乐欢了
Alice: Oh, I read it as willing to be happy.
Alice: 啊乐观啊
Alice: Ah, optimistic.
Alice: 乐观乐观
Alice: Optimistic, optimistic.
Alice: 我说嘛乐观是个什么东西
Alice: I was wondering what willing to be happy meant.
Lucia: 你如生活的
Lucia: It's about how you live your life.
Alice: 哇哇蛋你没事吧
Alice: Wow, wow, are you okay?
Lucia: 热爱什么鬼鬼
Lucia: What kind of passion is this?
Shure:  复旦使者
Shure: Fudan envoy.
Shure:  你的任务巨大我跟你讲
Shure: You have a huge mission, let me tell you.
Jake: 还有11分钟才到
Jake: There's still 11 minutes to go.
Jake: 所以放地上吧
Jake: So just put it down.
Alice: 蛋没事
Alice: The egg is fine.
Jake: 就放这吧
Jake: Just leave it here.
Shure:  洋葱买的吧
Shure: Did you buy onions?
Shure:  洋葱买的
Shure: Onions, right?
Alice: 买了紫皮的
Alice: Yes, I bought the purple ones.
Alice:啊有点累
Alice: Ah, I'm a bit tired.
Jake: 这样可以拍吧
Jake: Can we film this way?
Shure:  什么奇怪的事情
Shure: What a strange thing.
Lucia: 你醒了
Lucia: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了哈哈哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: You're awake! Hahaha, that's brilliant.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Alice: 啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake: 好就这样吧
Jake: Alright, let's leave it at that.
Shure:  来我们叫醒一下AI
Shure: Come on, let's wake up the AI.
Jake: 就这样挺好
Jake: This is good enough.
Jake: 来来来叫醒叫醒一下
Jake: Come on, wake him up.
Jake: 叫醒服务
Jake: Wake-up call.
Lucia: 呃他的手机
Lucia: Uh, his phone.
Shure:  咱们一个一个露出来吧
Shure: Let's reveal them one by one.
Shure:  咱们先拍一张
Shure: Let's take a photo first.
Shure:  然后拍个视频
Shure: Then shoot a video.
Katrina:  1234还差一个人呢
Katrina: 1234, we're missing one person.
Lucia: 要合个影
Lucia: Let's take a group photo.
Shure:  喝牛奶喝的
Shure: Drinking milk.
Shure:  有一人没露出来快快快
Shure: Someone's not in the shot, hurry up.
Jake: 快快快
Jake: Hurry, hurry!
Lucia: 完了再来一次
Lucia: Done, let's do it again.
Alice:还没带眼镜呢
Alice: I haven't put on my glasses yet.
Lucia: 没戴眼镜
Lucia: No glasses.
Shure:  而且你没戴眼镜
Shure: And you're not wearing glasses.
Lucia: 没戴眼镜来
Alice:来了
Alice: I'm here.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You're awake.
Shure:  那已经是2077年了
Shure: It's already the year 2077.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 等会我把这个带上忘了
Jake: Wait, I forgot to bring this.
Shure:  Wifi没带上
Shure: You didn't bring the WiFi.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没
Jake: Hahahahahaha no way.
Shure:  哈哈哈接收不着信号了
Shure: Hahaha, now we can't get a signal.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Alice: 我来了我来了
Alice: I'm here, I'm here.
Lucia: 马上收不到信号了
Lucia: We're about to lose the signal.
Shure:  是吗让自己看的像个活人一样
Shure: Really? Make yourself look alive.
Alice: 怎么按反了呢啊
Alice: Why did I press it the wrong way?
Alice: 没有
Alice: No.
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 有点歪呃没关系歪对啊
Jake: It's a bit crooked, but it's okay. Crooked is fine.
Alice: 有点歪说实话
Alice: It's a bit crooked, to be honest.
Lucia: 哈哈搅动转场
Lucia: Haha, let's spin the transition.
Jake: 好再来
Jake: Alright, let's do it again.
Alice: 呵呵
Alice: Hehe.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 这次很好
Jake: This time it's great.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay
Jake: 那视频一个一个出
Jake: Then, let's release the videos one by one.
Jake: 一个一个进来
Jake: Bring them in one by one.
Jake: 然后你醒了
Jake: And then you wake up.
Jake: 你醒了你醒了
Jake: You wake up, you wake up.
Katrina:  要说这句话是吗
Katrina: Should I say this?
Jake: 呵要吗
Jake: Haha, should you?
Jake: 可以要
Jake: You can if you want.
Shure:  好快快先撤出来
Shure: Alright, hurry, let's move out first.
Alice: 来呀谁呀
Alice: Come on, who is it?
Shure:  从杨老板开始
Shure: Let's start with Jake.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You woke up.
Alice: 你醒了
Alice: You woke up.
Jake: 进来就呆着
Jake: Just stay when you come in.
Jake: 重来重来重来
Jake: Do it again, do it again.
Shure:  哎重来没有默契没有啊
Shure: Hey, again, no coordination at all.
Tasha: 什么你醒了
Tasha: What, you woke up?
Alice: 你醒了
Alice: You woke up.
Jake: 来来来闪开
Jake: Come on, move aside.
Lucia: 那个表情包
Lucia: That meme.
Tasha: 哦哦醒了
Tasha: Oh oh, woke up.
Lucia: 你醒了快起来做作业哈哈
Lucia: You woke up, get up and do your homework, haha.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You woke up.
Alice: 醒了
Alice: Woke up.
Lucia: 你醒了
Lucia: You woke up.
Tasha: 醒了
Tasha: Woke up.
Katrina:  你醒了
Katrina: You woke up.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You woke up.
Katrina:  啊你啊
Katrina: Ah, you.
Shure:  你醒了吗
Shure: Are you awake?
Jake: 2077啊哈哈哈哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: 2077, hahaha, idiot.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈卧槽
Katrina: Hahaha, oh crap.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我靠哈
Tasha: Hahaha, oh damn.
Lucia: 哈哈瞬间变恐怖片
Lucia: Haha, it instantly turned into a horror movie.
Jake: 我靠很难
Jake: Oh damn, it's hard.
Jake: 哈哈哈直接晕倒
Jake: Haha, just faint right away.
Alice: 你不要过来呀
Alice: Don't come over!
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈根本醒不了
Jake: Hahaha, can't wake up at all
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Shure:  捡到了
Shure: Found it
Jake: 扮演车
Jake: Play the car
Jake: 还有8分钟
Jake: 8 more minutes
Jake: 还能再整点活
Jake: We can do a bit more
Lucia: 想看一眼那个视频
Lucia: I want to see that video
Jake: 好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay
Jake: 好慢啊
Jake: So slow
Lucia: 新物种生
Lucia: New species born
Jake: 傻吊
Jake: Silly
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Alice: 有鬼
Alice: There's a ghost
Katrina:  太恐怖了这
Katrina: This is so scary
Jake: 新物种生活确实
Jake: Life of new species, indeed
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Alice: 有脏东西哈哈
Alice: There's something dirty, haha
Shure:  我靠新物种生活
Shure: Wow, new species life
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Shure:  上面这字还很应景
Shure: The text above is so fitting
Jake: 个最后一天的开场视频都有了
Jake: Got the opening video for the last day
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  我那个叫什么10秒点出率
Shure: What’s that called, 10-second rate
Shure:  对哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, haha
Shure:  就卡在我那10秒了
Shure: Got stuck at my 10 seconds
Jake: 丰收歌曲
Jake: Harvest song
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay
Alice: 快递快递
Alice: Delivery, delivery
Alice: 你必须给我快点
Alice: You have to hurry up for me
Shure:  （歌词）自由经过了山
Shure: (lyrics) Freedom passed through the mountains
Shure:  （歌词）我想开着我的烂摩托转一转
Shure: (lyrics) I want to ride my broken motorcycle around
Shure: （歌词） 可惜我的心
Shure: (lyrics) But unfortunately my heart
Shure:  （歌词）我可惜我把车卖了
Shure: (lyrics) Unfortunately I sold my bike
Shure: （歌词） 我的心呀我的心
Shure: (lyrics) My heart, my heart
Shure:  （歌词）变成了处处处处都给你
Shure: (lyrics) Everywhere, everywhere gives it to you
Alice: 还有大概半个小时能录
Alice: About half an hour more to record
Jake: 没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake: 就上车就关掉
Jake: Just turn it off once we get in the car.
Lucia: 当前网络不稳定
Lucia: The current network is unstable.
Shure:  （歌词）躲在屋檐的
Shure: (lyrics) Hiding under the eaves
Alice:好累呀
Alice: So tired.
Jake: 这地挺酷
Jake: This place is pretty cool.
Shure:  啊你在拍照啊
Shure: Oh, you're taking a picture.
Shure:  你浪费我的表情了
Shure: You wasted my expression.
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Hehe.
Jake: 你从后面绕过来吧
Jake: Go around from the back.
Jake: 要不就我
Jake: Or maybe I'll...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 我开始我开始录了
Jake: I'm starting, I'm starting to record.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 还有5分钟
Jake: Five more minutes.
Jake: 出去等着吧
Jake: Go out and wait.
Jake: 走吧出去吧
Jake: Let's go, let's head out.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  （歌词）起来饥寒交迫的人
Shure: (lyrics) Rise up, people suffering from hunger and cold
Shure:  （歌词）在全世界
Shure: (lyrics) Across the whole world
Shure:  杨老板哎
Shure: Jake, hey.
Shure:  别客气哎呀呀呀呀
Shure: Don't be polite, oh my.
Shure:  行吧那就给你吧
Shure: Alright, I'll give it to you.
Jake: 蛋呢蛋在蛋在哪
Jake: Where are the eggs, where are the eggs?
Jake: 蛋在哪啊
Jake: Where are the eggs?
Shure:  弹不好弹
Shure: It's hard to play.
Alice:在这呢
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  你在反复欣赏那个视频是吗我天
Shure: Are you rewatching that video again? Oh my.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 没有最帅的人
Jake: There's no one more handsome.
Alice: 你没有反复吧哈哈
Alice: You didn't watch it again, did you? Haha.
Lucia: 把我吓得又倒头就睡真的
Lucia: It scared me so much that I immediately fell asleep again, really.
Jake:这是哪啊
Jake: Where is this place?
Jake: 走上到路口
Jake: Walk up to the intersection.
Jake: 这过得去吧
Jake: Can we get through here?
Shure:  过得去从哪过
Shure: Get through, but from where?
Tasha: 那当然是翻山越岭
Tasha: Of course, it's over the mountains.
Shure:  他到哪了
Shure: Where did he go?
Shure:  我看一眼
Shure: Let me take a look.
Jake: 三分钟
Jake: Three minutes.
Shure:  就在咱们面前是吧
Shure: It's right in front of us, right?
Shure:  那咱们从那绕一下吧走吧
Shure: Let's go around from there, shall we?
Jake: 啊他
Jake: Ah, him.
Jake: 他说可以开进来
Jake: He said we can drive in.
Shure:  不这是非机动车道
Shure: No, this is the bike lane.
Shure:  他进不来的
Shure: He can't drive in.
Jake: 那要不怎么照
Jake: Then how do we take the photo?
Tasha: 哎你小心摄像头
Tasha: Hey, watch out for the camera.
Tasha: 我是说钻的时候
Tasha: I meant when you're squeezing through.
Shure:  要钻过去是吧
Shure: You mean we have to squeeze through, right?
Jake: 哎从旁边不能过吗
Jake: Hey, can't we go around the side?
Shure:  旁边
Shure: The side?
Shure:  真费劲吧
Shure: It's really a hassle, isn't it?
Shure:  杨老板你你你你能吗
Shure: Jake, can you manage it?
Jake: 哈哈哈我有可能的吧
Jake: Haha, it's possible for me, right?
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  哦这辆什么
Shure: Oh, what's this?
Shure:  337是吗
Shure: Is it 337?
Shure:  啊不是
Shure: Ah, no.
Tasha: 那就是
Tasha: That's it.
Tasha: 是这辆吗好吧
Tasha: Is it this one? Okay.
Tasha: 这辆吗
Tasha: This one?
Jake: 棕色别克
Jake: Brown Buick.
Jake: 776
Jake: 776.
Jake: 那个像吗
Jake: Does that look like it?
Jake: 那车后轮
Jake: The car's rear wheel.
Shure:  有点像
Shure: Looks a bit like it.
Shure:  疑似
Shure: Suspected.
Shure:  776 对没错
Shure: 776, right, that's it.
Tasha: 这是棕色吗
Tasha: Is this brown?
Jake: 就是他
Jake: That's it.
Jake: 太对了
Jake: Exactly right.
Tasha: 都是打领带的
Tasha: They're all wearing ties.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  要放后备箱吗
Katrina: Should we put it in the trunk?
Alice: 要要要
Alice: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 哎不放后备箱吗
Lucia: Hey, aren't we putting it in the trunk?
Alice: 不放后备箱吗
Alice: Aren't we putting it in the trunk?
Shure:  啊尾号7008是吧
Shure: Ah, the last digits are 7008, right?
Jake: 对对可对了
Jake: Yes, yes, that's right.
Shure:  啊 7008
Shure: Ah, 7008.
Lucia: 要不放一下吧
Lucia: How about we play it?
Shure:  不是哪有后备箱啊你想想
Shure: No, there's no trunk, think about it.
Lucia: 啊没有啊没有
Lucia: Ah, no, there's none.
Alice: 没有没有
Alice: No, no.
其他人：不是你要有箱子啊
Others: No, you need a box.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake: 没箱子
Jake: No box.
Shure:  这这些上来就行
Shure: These, just put them on.
其他人：赶紧上啊
Others: Hurry up and put them on.
Alice:蛋啊你可别碎啊
Alice: Eggs, don't you dare break.
Jake: 呀再次保安位
Jake: Ah, back to security position.
Alice:蛋没事吧
Alice: The eggs are fine, right?
Jake: 关吧
Jake: Close it.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Lucia: 理论上说是不是我
Lucia: Theoretically, isn't it me...
Alice:停吧
Alice: Stop.
Lucia: 应该是保安
Lucia: Should be the security.
Lucia: 然后我下去刚好给你们一开门
Lucia: Then I'll go down and open the door for you.
Alice:这个可以停了吗
Alice: Can we stop this now?
Shure:  没有把它录了放冰箱里吧
Shure: No, record it and put it in the fridge.
Jake: 大车开始撸
Jake: The big car starts now.
Jake: 我录完放冰箱
Jake: I'll record it and put it in the fridge.
Jake: 放到冰箱就给我导
Jake: Once it's in the fridge, transfer it to me.